what's up Stephanie what can I help with
so I have a question about productivity
yeah and so every morning I get up I
watch you have the whole morning ritual
money routine but I'm in the process of
starting at brand-new brand centered all
around positivity motivation inspiration
and helping people learn about just the
best way to get their morning started
but I also have a digital marketing
agency at the same time and I was going
to utilize my digital marketing agency
to fund my new brands so how do you
bridge the gap because I know that yeah
I know that you have your dance studio
and I know that you're doing the same
time so how do I climb it so I think
this is dependent personality for me I
have a really hard time switching tasks
like even doing this is difficult I have
to go from this going back to my book
this it's really difficult it's hard for
me to switch the tasks and I think it's
hard for people in general but for me
it's especially hard and so what I love
doing is having different things on
different days okay and so for me Monday
is my mentoring day so I spend the
entire day mentoring my team and so
that's that's tedious it's my dance
studio because I don't do it much in the
day-to-day at the dance studio my main
job is mentoring Alex who's running the
studio then I spend time with Lilly
who's building her business like month
that's my day Wednesday is my project
day so like I want to make progress on
this book right now
like boom Wednesday all day I'm just
sitting here or I'm standing there on my
trampoline like doing this book right
and so I do different things in
different days and that works really
really well from for me and my
personality so if I was jumping into
your business that's what I would do I'd
have here's my day that I do like you
have you want to retain great and then
there may be some things that you have
to do every day like you have to check
your email and you have to get back to
clients and you gotta whatever but apart
from that like I'd be looking at maybe
maybe you start by doing your afternoons
every afternoon you're doing something
different so like
the afternoon your agency Tuesday
afternoon is your positivity brand
Wednesday afternoon maybe you're back to
your agency right and you split it up
and I do it for two reasons one because
it helps me stay focused on the thing
because it would be it'd be really hard
for me to jump into your business and
then do an hour and productivity or an
hour on the agency in an hour on the
brand and then like go back and forth
that beast too much switching costs
right and to I miss it like I miss it so
so Thursday is my public-facing day
where I'm doing interviews and podcasts
and hangouts and Skype calls and radio
shows and all that stuff so that's
tomorrow but tomorrow sunny all day
back-to-back interviews for me but then
nothing in between
so then like I miss it like I look
forward to it happening at home like
Thursday yeah I've done in a while right
I miss it as opposed to being like a
drag or a negative sometimes like
yesterday was my YouTube filming day has
been the whole day researching and
filming my videos and then I'm not gonna
touch it again until next Tuesday
and so I miss it like I don't miss it
right now because I just did it
yesterday but come like Friday Saturdays
ago like I want to make some videos
right and so that works in my
personality that may be like the worst
thing ever for you because I'm like do I
do this or do I do this morning this
afternoon one of them like my agency
have had for a while but it's dormant
cuz I haven't had any help but now with
my new brand I have like a team of
creatives and we're like all the
information so um we love you so that's
what's been like what really drives me
right now but I think yeah separating
you know Mondays that's you think that I
think that's be really helpful I'm a big
believer that your actions have to map
to your ambitions and so you you could
talk a big game you have big ambitions
of like he was only with my agency and
this new brand and and also like life
and relationships and everything else
right like what is it what is a great
life for Stephanie look like awesome
yeah but like are your actions matching
it right and so that's where you have to
look at your calendar and say okay I
want to build this agency but I'm not
but in any time on it so Tuesday
afternoons agency right and it's a
constant like your schedule in in three
months won't be exactly the same right
so right before before I took on Lily I
don't know if you followed Lily or her
progress or anything but I wanted to
build an entrepreneur cafe okay that was
my ID like I wanted a local entrepreneur
I can wanted to look little Starbucks
but like my own thing
we're entrence to come and work and we'd
have like videos on the on the wall and
like business plans to look through with
just a place for entrepreneurs to hang
out but in taking on Lily I couldn't do
that business okay so so I decided Lily
or the cafe I'm picking Lily okay now in
a year that may change right I might be
on to something else but you're you
always want to be paying attention to
like where am I being pulled like I'm
being pulled in this new direction but
there's no time for me to to do that
thing yet so in order for that to happen
I have to take something else away okay
so it's a constant evaluation it's like
every quarter I don't have a set date
that like once a quarter I look at it
but when you feel like your time is
being stretched it's a case of poor
planning and so you have to go back to
your schedule and say okay I need to I
need to plan Barney to cut something
else out to make time for this new like
you're launching this new positivity
brand yeah you you're not magically
gifted an extra two hours a day to work
on this right so it's like something has
to come out and yes you could be more
productive awesome great but like
something has to come out so now what's
going to be removed so you can focus on
this new thing and so it's that constant
evaluation of your your schedule to make
sure that your actions are mapping your
ambitions and the life you want to build
for yourself yeah here's a little quick
hack of how I do it okay
that may be that may be really helpful
like there's a lot of things that I'd
like to test I will test it and I will
stretch I will stretch myself to do the
test so an example I don't know if you
know sadguru or not he's this like
Indian yogi guru guy and we did a video
with him and I was gonna do a one I was
gonna go to his event in Philadelphia
and part of that meant you had to do
seven days of
with his videos and they were like 45
minutes or an hour each or something I
don't have 45 minutes to an hour every
night to do the meditation videos like
my calendar is fully locked in so that's
gonna take away time from my wife and in
my family my relationship so I
on-boarded her as an Nena like let's do
this together
instead of instead of relaxed on the
couch and like watching something
together going for a walk with the dogs
we're gonna we're gonna spend the time
meditating with sadguru for the next
week so like I'll stretch myself right
I'll stay I'll stretch but I can't
stretch myself forever right so idea at
the end of the week I need to decide am
I going to if I'm gonna keep this
meditation habit then something has to
come out of my calendar for this to work
okay right so and if it doesn't then I
saw it the ants the short answer is like
I didn't keep it that's okay but that's
what I'll do like I'll test stuff and
I'll see like this is something that I
want to spend more time on and if it is
then I need to find some way to fit into
my calendar that means something comes
out but I'll be constant like trying to
test different things where if you're if
you're always you can't rely on the
burning the candle at both ends all the
time right so like if I wanted to make
that meditation have it stick then I
would need to find a spot on my calendar
to do it gotcha okay okay okay thank you
thank you all right good luck Stephanie
also if you want to know what I think
and what other successful entrepreneurs
think about building confidence check
out my new 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days
for free I will send you a 30 second a
five minute video in the morning to help
you build unstoppable confidence the
link is in the description below if you
want to be more confident you need to
surround yourself with things that make
you feel confident realizing that any
big endeavor is the collection of a lot
of small steps that came before if
you're doing work that you love you're
more likely to follow through you're
more likely to do it because it doesn't
feel like work because you love doing it
raise your standard Apple at the core is
corn
is that we believe that people with
passion and now one drop of myself work
depends on your acceptance of me if you
want to learn more about how to create a
life-changing morning routine check out
the video right next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
there is one habit that I have adopted
in the last three years that has
fundamentally changed me as a business
person